you pull this together thank you very
much listen thank you one of the things
this movie explores is that age-old
questions do Opposites Attract I am
curious what's an opposing trait that
you saw in Mila in those early days of
dating that you thought was really
attractive
what were that what were the uh
qualities that I saw in Mila in the
early days of dating that were like
Opposites Attract attractive
um she is very sensible
Ashton are you not sensible nailed it am
I not sensible
get Jewish gown there you go
but you gotta feel like you two kind of
balance each other out do you
yeah I I Olean actually answered the
question perfect I was gonna say like
I'm a dreamer she's an Executor
um and that would be like the opposite
functions that we serve like I'm like we
should go on a road trip across the
United States and she goes okay and then
plans every stop and make sure that it's
dialed in make it happen yeah and but
that actually happened
um and and we just got in a sprinter van
and drove through the national parts of
the United States because she was like
she playing the whole damn thing like if
you want to do it we got to do it right
yeah I bought I got the Sprinter van
I came up with the idea she executed
it's a huge life goal I love that what
is all this Peter's not interested in me
like that is he
I feel like we should see what you and I
could be
this is a minor setback right all you
have to do is take a chance I don't take
chances you know this movie got me
looking at my friends thinking like is
there someone under my nose that I'm not
like paying attention to that could be
the one you know but because I haven't
been there no I you know I haven't been
as Lucky in Love But I feel like I take
something from every day every
relationship so I mean for you looking
at this movie and in your own life how
would you say your past relationships
have shaped you
you know I usually think that in life
the thing you want is one step away you
just have to figure out which direction
to step
and I I genuinely feel that like
everything we want it's really about
it's not about like the momentum it's
about the trajectory and if and
sometimes we just aren't aren't seeing
the exact things that are directly in
front of us and and and I think that
counts for relationship that counts for
work that counts for everything it's
like setting an intention and setting a
trajectory that's appropriate and then
taking that step that's everything in
the difference amen I'm taking notes on
that one hey good to see you
congratulations
foreign